House Speaker Nancy Pelosi now for weeks
the speaker trying to play petty
political games with this nation and the
State of the Union and the president by
the way what is she fighting for
president fighting life and death
presidents fighting safety and security
well she is barred the president from
performing his constitutional duty in
the House chamber making her the first
speaker in US history to ever do so she
refused to compromise on budget
negotiations wouldn't even come to the
table to talk about any kind of deal
she's been too busy on our luxurious
vacations other Democrats on a lobbyist
pay junket again luxurious locations and
resorts planning taxpayer-funded
excursions around the globe and to even
talk to the president was offered
dramatic compromises things she has said
over the years she wants and she has no
time for that but today the president he
rose above her bitter petty partisan
gamesmanship he postponed the State of
the Union some seemed upset by this they
want the president to go to an
alternative location but I think it's a
bad idea why because the president to
give up the grandeur giving the State of
the Union in the House chamber mr.
speaker the President of the United
States that is a powerful moment you
have Congress men and women and senators
literally staking out their seats so
they could shake the president's hand 14
hours ahead of time no other place can
match that symbolic location the
grandeur and this president deserves
nothing less and I'm sure that will
happen in the near future this is about
so much more though than politics this
is about your safety your security
this is about the safety of the country
and literally life and death now this is
about a president fulfilling a promise
to secure our southern border this is
about saving American lives that are
impacted by gangs cartels drugs violence
this life and death
people are dying 90 percent of that
heroin that gets into this country comes
from that border it's about 10,000 new
migrants now obtaining visas from the
government of Mexico to travel through
the country in order to make their way
north into our country because we have
unsecured borders now when the US
government
is reopened the president will hold his
State of the Union where it belongs in
the House chambers with members of both
parties hopefully present in the
meantime the shutdown does continue the
president has been unrelenting fighting
to make the country safer Democrats
continue to feed their insatiable
appetite this pathological hatred this
division that they have and of course
it's always about a desire for power and
breaking tonight the White House is
reportedly now drafting a national
emergency order and allocating seven
billion dollars for that wall that would
require zero congressional approval and
today the president reassured Americans
that he will get guaranteed funds for
the wall one way or another let's take a
look well one of the ideas suggested as
they open it they pay a sort of a a
prorated down payment for the wall which
I think people will agree that you need
you need the wall
I have other alternatives if I have to
and I'll use those alternatives if I
have to we want to go through the system
we have to have a wall in this country
we have criminals pouring into our
country we have no choice but to have a
wall or barrier and if we don't have
that it's just not gonna work again I
asked what does Nancy Pelosi fighting
for what's in the best interest of the
country now President Trump remains
ready willing to negotiate with the
Democratic leadership the White House
doors they're wide open he's willing to
compromise as he has shown time and
again he's even willing to take a
pro-rated funding rate for the wall for
a short period of time give Congress
again another chance to do their job and
find a resolution but if the stalemate
continues it's obvious Democrats refused
to come to the table the president is
clear he will declare a national
emergency and solve the problem himself
may take some time to fight in the
courts but in my opinion he will win and
by the way that will happen
unfortunately as we showed you last
night Nancy Pelosi
seems to be standing for nothing but
being against Trump during the height of
budget negotiation she and several other
top Democrats they tried to slip away
for that seven days oversea junket
courtesy of you the taxpayer and of
course nothing new for Pelosi look at
this according to Joe
juwatch during her last term as Speaker
she racked up a massive travel bill with
the US Air Force over a two-year period
she spent more than two million dollars
of your money on air travel 100,000 of
which was in flight expenses that means
food and booze for all those politicians
for working so hard like half the year
thankfully the president put the kibosh
on her most recent overseas junket and
today we did send Fox News contributor
our friend Lawrence Jones to the streets
of New York City to see what Americans
really think about the radical extreme
socialist Democratic Speaker Nancy
Pelosi and her so-called leadership
let's take a look
Trump in the first President American
history to be disinvited from the State
of the Union right how do you feel about
this well I can't believe it it's
graceful absolutely absolutely I cannot
believe that ever happened in the United
States to try to cancel something
because of your politics you're not
honoring oh yeah that's wrong I think
Nancy Pelosi is doing the right thing
because Donald Trump is destroying this
country by his rhetoric in his racism
and a million other things and I think
Nancy Pelosi is the voice of reason in
this country do you feel like Nancy
Pelosi was wrong yes I believe the
president should attend it should be his
choice whether or not he wants to attend
or not attend what he's doing to this
country is an abomination and people's
rights human rights are being violated
what what human rights are being
violated what human rights tell me um
the list goes don't fill me the list
goes on now she said that this was
because of security but they said that's
not true did she tell a lie no she said
she had some security concerns yeah
which I believe she probably does as
depression but she didn't talk to the
necessary people to figure that out
it doesn't matter do you think it's
eroding the institution I mean this
doesn't mean that you agree with the
president
everything but this is his report card
to the country and to Congress right
well looks of childish you know and I
believe that there was a terrible thing
that Nancy Pelosi did to the president
for her to cancel that and go against
the Constitution speaks speaks volumes
so the she throwing a temper tantrum of
her home right now that's a really good
question
you think Nancy blows to take a meeting
with the president get some type of
package burst research that's her job
do your job just do your job
pouting a good question Oh what human
rights are being violated
they've been violated whatever they are
they're they're violated you can't make
this up of course that's New York City
California New York not exactly
representing red state America anyway
sadly Nancy and Chuck you know being
controlled by the most radical the most
extreme elements in the new socialist
Democratic Party these are the same
far-left individuals who are now playing
kingmakers in the upcoming 2020
presidential primary and that brings us
to tonight's Hannity Watch report on the
2020 race we see nearly every single
Democrat who has announced their
candidacy the first thing they do is I
got to apologize for this position I had
that may sound conservative or you'll
hate me at Kirsten Gillibrand she
apologized for one supporting the second
amendment that you have Tulsi Gabbard
apologizing for her mixed track record
on social issues yet somehow was still
waiting on Elizabeth Warren's apology
for faking and benefiting paula lie of
saying she's a Native American Lauren
did however find some time to propose
brand-new taxes right there check it out
she's always finding new and creative
ways to pick your pocket and penalize
Americans that she describes as wealthy
somehow she wants to take that money and
redistribute it and meanwhile one of
Warren's 2020 primary opponent senator
Kamala Harris is spending her time
raising an enormous amount of money
buying up all the Facebook ads that she
can find and of course trashing the
president and she wants him to open up
Trump Tower as his shelter
the victims of the shutdown there are
other people that own those units he
actually sold them they're not his take
a look people are worried about eviction
you know what listen I you know what I
think should happen if the president
feels as strongly about it then open up
the trunk tower and let everybody be in
city living there rent-free and then
maybe we can start having a discussion
I mean February Betty's got some rules
have you here first is going to be rent
day for a lot of people who rely on
matter
all right Camaros Kamala Harris is a
member of Congress she can open up her
home Nancy Pelosi's of
multi-multi-millionaire what do we see
when we sent Lawrence to her district
needles feces homeless people everywhere
why doesn't she build the homeless
shelter there oh that's right she they
were only generous with your money there
like you said it's not a joking matter
in this sense in the coming weeks this
crop of Democrats vying to replace
President Trump is likely to get bigger
and bigger but the moderates are nowhere
to be found